on the Prime Minister's bus in the
middle of the night we are just leaving
torbay and heading for Bristol here's
day I'm ad getting all their kit
together and this is the Tory gift pack
with a blanket and blazoned with a
lovely conservative tree and we've got
pillows too we're awake if a bit sleepy
and if they were heading into Wales from
alling with farmers plus is going down a
very narrow Patrick in brecon and Ragnar
sure which is a fight between the Tories
and the lib dems proposes the reason
they walk person this is Caroline who's
been looking after so much of this bus
journey there is a farmhouse where the
Prime Minister is doing a walk about
with the family who live there lovely
here in brecon though it's very very
cold so we've been traveling for quite a
long time we've been to a lot of lib dem
seats but we are now about to change in
direction going more today to Tory seats
where labour are very close behind
Cameron was on the attack yesterday he
is on the defense today we're going to
Cannock Chase with these two but right
there I will be jumping off this bus for
the last time